feel like my thumbnail should be like
yeah I'll do this sure so the Super
Mario Bros movie it's out it's been seen
and reviewed by critics been seen by
some audience members and
[Music]
contrast that divide that we've we've
seen before is alive and well here for
this movie and that makes me go
I'll do another video about that movie
so this is my spoiler talk for the Super
Mario Brothers movie it's not gonna be a
play-by-play none of my spoiler talks
are also the spoilers in this movie are
generally going to revolve around Easter
eggs that I'm gonna be real with you I'm
not gonna remember all of them so just
keep all this in mind over here having a
good time talking about things I didn't
talk about my spoiler free review of the
movies here we go you know the thing I
liked about this movie is it starts out
like it just gets going Bowser and his
floating Castle just comes down on those
penguins and he's like let's wreck some
penguins it's essentially the scene from
the teaser trailer takes the star and
now we know bad guys up to bad guy
things and now we're in Brooklyn we're
the Super Mario Brothers is actually the
name of Mario and Luigi's plumber
service they are the Super Mario
Brothers don't lie that's actually some
pretty good marketing also the song on
their commercial is the intro song to
the Super Mario Brothers Super Show
which I don't even know at this point if
that's a deep cut or just the logical
thing to do probably both but I feel
like not everyone's going to get that
unless you were there in the late 80s
watching Punky Brewster and Super Mario
Bros other Super Show back to back
before you relate to the bus stop but
you caught the bus on its way back
unless that was you I might be
projecting point is love seeing that
song in here but the Easter eggs in this
movie they started early and they did
not stop again bear with me I'm not
gonna remember all of them I don't sit
there with little skadoodle pad riding
down everything and movie screenings
also I'm not a [__] with a notepad
on his phone having his phone open
during the movie I was right right I
like being engaged with the movie I go
home I word vomit what I remember for
your enjoyment on the YouTubes but yeah
I was like whoa punch out pictures these
Super Punch Out Fighters pictures of
them on the wall Mario's playing
Nintendo Mario is playing an NES look
I'm gonna be honest with you I try to
watch my language in these videos that
revolve around kids movies because I'm
like little kids might watch these
videos also I'm not a [__] but Mario
playing the NES it's the most meta [__]
I've ever seen move over anything in any
Scream movie Mario's playing the NES
everyone else every movie reference
anything can enjoy the silver medal this
one kind of takes it also you hear
Charles Martin a in this movie he is in
this movie just doesn't Voice Mario that
is of course Chris Pratt but I thought
that was a fun little spin that they did
we're in their commercial they have
these really exaggerated Italian accents
and they sound like Mario and Luigi from
the games and then cut to real life well
real life animated right where they were
like oh is that too much and Charles
Martin a and his Mario voice is like oh
it's perfect thing is though you're
dealing with Hollywood Studios and all
sorts of soulless life forms so you know
I don't know how that started or ended
up could have been like oh yeah we have
him in the movie because you know he's
gotta be or the internet was like why
didn't you cast him and they were like
uh hey can you just say this one line
into the microphone fantastic thank you
here's five bucks and now we can have
that in the movie fantastic but I felt
it played well he's also credited as
voicing Mario's dad as well so I mean
you gotta assume he was always cast in
the movie but anyhow but also yeah we
see the Mario family and it does lead
into you know Mario's on his Hero's
Quest he's the down on his luck doesn't
feel like he's a mountain to anything in
life kind of hero gotta know though are
their last names still Mario
things to ponder a thing that did crack
me up in here in a world where I wanted
to talk more about it my spoiler-free
video but I'm like all right just just
give the information is it enjoyable is
it not let's go spoiler talks I can take
more time to talk about Bowser pining
for peach in his off time
that just cracks me up it cracks me up
because every villain has these
unflattering moments we just don't see
on screen and we always just see them in
their Prime villain form but in between
it's like what's their in-between time
like and in between each game Bowser is
scheming and pining for peach he has to
be that's why history being written by
The Victors I have my own fan theory
that Bowser and Peach are actually the
couple and every game is you playing as
the villain breaking into Bowser's house
stealing his girlfriend and that's the
end anyhow yeah what does this dude do
in his off time he probably makes weird
little songs about peach in his off time
I like seeing that because you know you
think about
think about the Joker Heath Ledger's
Joker right generally when we see him we
see him enacting his master plan
bringing Gotham to its knees with a few
Drums of gas and a couple of bullets but
afterwards just cracks me up to think at
the end of the day the dude gets home or
wherever he rests he has his little
makeup wipes he just takes the makeup
off you know he's sleeping does he talk
in his sleep
I don't know probably right we never get
to see that with villains it did kind of
crack me up that we did this time my
favorite part of the movie the thing I
laughed at the most probably lumily yeah
that dark depressing little Luma in the
cage
it's I kept thinking like dude this is a
kid's movie there's gonna be some
parents for their kids kids are gonna be
like what what's that dad and why is the
little fire acting so dark parents get
to try to evade the truth but or they
can just be truthful and be like that
well that is what you get to become one
day that's what we all become after
working 52 hours a week with no overtime
working for the man
enjoy your childhood while you have it
yeah lumily was messed up show stealer
so when we're out there on our adventure
Peach Mario and Toad they're like look
we need help from the Kongs if we're
gonna do this right when we got to DK
country you start seeing what they're
doing like oh yeah
a Nintendo World I'd actually love to
see a Donkey Kong Country movie that'd
be fun and yeah in my review when I said
there was a character that was cast but
I could have gone for the character
sounding older and crankier yeah for
those of you who didn't have a touring
test to crack that inspired code I was
talking about Cranky Kong just Fred
Armisen as Cranky Kong I wasn't seeing
it wasn't feeling it in a perfect world
Ed Asner he's not with us anymore so of
those still here
um Alan Arkin I think would be a great
choice if you're looking for cranky and
funny in the movie he didn't have that
back in my day kind of grumpy old man
energy that Cranky Kong had in Donkey
Kong Country he just came across as
younger and cooler like he was cranky
Kong's brother with a longer beard
definitely related to Funky Kong maybe
it was funky Kong's dad like cool hippie
Kong maybe that's what they were going
for because Seth Rogen voiced Donkey
Kong which again I think was great in
the movie you know Seth Rogen he's on
the record saying oh he's just phoned it
in he's gonna be lazy in this movie but
I guess that's kind of the point Seth
Rogen phoning it in as voicing Donkey
Kong was still perfect for Donkey Kong
because let's face it Seth Rogen's a big
Stoner ape I would imagine Seth Rogen
has a weed horde that's every bit as big
as Donkey Kong's banana horde the
kremlings ever stole his weed horde I'm
sure he'd have the same reaction Donkey
Kong had when he came in walking in on
his banana horde being gone Seth Rogen
get James Franco going an adventure
together trying to get it back from the
kremlings are they still friends I
I don't know I don't care you know what
I'm saying I know I'm talking about weed
in a video talking about a kid's movie
shocking but it's legal most everywhere
if I was from Portland I could talk
about black tar heroin but I'm not I did
call BS on that whole Peach beat the
obstacle course in one try it's this
whole montage of Mario trying this
obstacle course Peach does it yeah but
you know you're like okay she's done
this course before and she was like oh
no it takes everyone a few tries and
Mario's like you did it once didn't you
she was like yeah I did it first try
that makes no sense to me she's like
well I grew up here
everyone who's ever with
whipsical course that you've ever seen
grew up on Earth where the obstacle
course takes place just because you're
in the world doesn't mean you're good at
obstacle courses Mario if you can do the
obstacle course you're good enough to
come along with me I did that for your
health we need to know that you're not
gonna die
oh toad you want to go too
sure let's do it don't worry about the
obstacle course there are a lot of toads
in this world you're very replaceable
huh what did like the obstacle course
but that's one of the things I had in
mind when I was saying I could have gone
for more platforming Adventures like
real dangers out there again the last
act definitely has all of that before
that we have a Mario Kart segment which
doesn't feel like a Super Mario Brothers
game it's a Mario Kart game it's
completely different game he fights
Donkey Kong again not really Super Mario
game but he also did an obstacle course
the obstacle course did have that Mario
64 energy you know because we're dealing
with 3D environments and so I I did like
that but it was still an obstacle course
it was a training course it wasn't
actually danger could have gone for some
more Mario platforming Peril where they
feel like they're in danger Hammer
brothers are coming after them they
might die I did like how they dealt with
the power ups though something simple
like a mushroom power up would be so
easy to be like all right we're just
skipping past that Mario's is normal
size and that's all there is to it let's
just get on with the adventure but no
they're like peaches obviously 12 feet
tall and Mario is about half that
appreciated that Mario didn't like
mushrooms kind of reminded me of the
Popeye movie there were things in here
where I was like oh that's taken from
this other movie that one reminded me of
Popeye this iconic power up that this
character eats and becomes super powered
but in the movie doesn't actually like
the food but he's forced to eat it to
power up right Robin Williams Popeye
movie and Super Mario Brothers movie
regardless when he was picking all the
mushrooms off his plate I was like same
Mario
same mushrooms are
awful so then we have this Mario Kart
segment they get all the Kongs together
and they're going on the Rainbow Road
and then they have a lot of resistance a
lot of the Koopas are coming after them
like all right here we go now we're in a
Mario Kart game Movie game but this was
a segment where I was like watching the
movie not nearly as fun as playing the
game in fact watching someone play the
game is also more exciting but weirdly I
probably have that programmed into me
got home off the school bus the
neighbors watch us for a couple hours
while Mom finished work and the dad his
name is Wayne and he would play games
that's what he did he played Nintendo so
we were all just glued so watching
Nintendo's actually
it was fun for me but where's the Mario
Kart segment it was a cool thing it was
a fan service thing it would have been
cooler if they brought someone in who's
like hey I helped out on Ford V Ferrari
I'll make this look great I'll make this
intense never felt like that never
committed to being a racing segment that
would have been a pretty knock it out of
the park moment to do that still
Peach's Arch game is 10 out of 10.
you all thought it I'm just saying it
I'm not taking that out I don't care
because truth is an important thing so
at the very end of the movie after this
huge Bullet Bill Mario takes the Bullet
Bill to the pipe blows up everything
gets stucked into it and essentially
they all end up in Brooklyn so Bowser
it reminded me of of the 1993 movie
absolutely could have gone for Bowser
being like Brooklyn my world I don't
want to plagiarize Dennis Hopper too
much that's when we have a couple of
touching moments between Mario and Luigi
when Luigi has the manhole cover and
he's blocking the fire and he's telling
Mario to go get the star great scene
also made me be like yeah I know Mario
and Luigi are so good together
because
Superstar Saga baby also found it
touching and sweet when Mario sees their
commercial and they're saying hey we're
the Super Mario Brothers we're here to
save Brooklyn he's like what's the point
of saying it I gotta do it what can I
say I like moments like that I'm I'm
cheesy I don't care that was nice I was
like that commercial brings it full
circle go go to Mario get that star and
then they get the star they're running
through enemies you know what it looked
like it didn't even look like a Super
Mario Brothers game it looked like Mario
35 I don't know why they ever took that
away that was so much fun you have so
many enemies on screen you get that star
and you're just annihilating them yeah
look more like that
bring back Super Mario 35 that was fun
long story short the Super Mario
Brothers they saved the day Bowser's
little Bowser and he's in a cage he's in
a little Bowser cage I believe that was
one of the post-credits scenes everyone
like we all knew that there was another
post-credit scene you see all these
critics in this Auditorium everyone's
theorizing everyone's speculating the
whole time I was like
so why doesn't Big Boss wart ever come
back even a Mario and Luigi Dream Team I
was convinced it's a dream world game
obviously this is when wart's gonna come
back you're never dead but the Yoshi
Easter egg there it is I get it now a
Yoshi egg as a Yoshi Easter egg released
on Easter weekend with egg right
marketing genius good job tendo or
illumination at least but it was like oh
Yoshi's coming in but in the movie there
was a scene a quick Glimpse where you
see a bunch of Yoshis I think it would
have been more impactful if you didn't
see a glimpse of a bunch of Yoshi's
earlier in the movie and the first
reference of Yoshi was this egg that
cracked and you hear Yoshi say Yoshi
interesting observation there have been
three movies in as many weeks that have
used holding up for a hero in their film
I don't know you want to do with that
information Tetris used a different
iteration of it but still well
regardless the movie had one job and
that is to not totally suck I walked out
of the movie like I said you always want
a movie like this to be more epic I
wanted to walk out of this movie being
like this is the greatest animated
feature film I've seen in about 10 years
but as it stands it's an enjoyable time
at the very least people seem to be
coming out of the movie being like I
loved it my kids loved it I want to see
more from the world and that's what this
movie needed to do it at least needed
people to be like hey there's something
here I want to see more and legitimately
I am saying I think the reason this
movie landed with people is Brian
Tyler's musical score there are a lot of
gears at work to have something like
this land with fans or nail the tone
they're going for but music being the
language of the heart and soul
that was a big one all right so the
Super Mario Bros movie have you seen it
what did you think about it what's the
next Nintendo property you want to see
adapted whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
foreign